um
that's gonna be me today guys literally
have a sore throat a little bit stuffed
some mucousy
yep it's gonna be fun yeah let's just
sit here very blank-faced a lot of slime
watching the witcher kick us off john
you got 30 seconds all right guys it's
time for witcher season one episode four
go ahead and hit that like button if you
like this video remember to subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified the second our next witcher
reaction is up and if you want to watch
the full thing sync up with us at the
time code come on over to our patreon
page we got a bunch of shows over there
where you got the option for reaction
highlights as well as watch along
included cannot show the footage for the
watch alongs
gotta get that through but uh hey thanks
to prepper for cutting down these
highlights it is a task and we very much
appreciate their hard work now let's
jump into this very good
black panther
on your left cap
what is your name
fiona
where am i how did you are in broken
land forest brooklyn forest
swallowed
that witcher
oh
this is
brilliant
bard
it's just daryl's usually so stingy with
the details
uh and then what happened
he died
he's
fine i saw it with my up
see
[Laughter]
man knows how to make an entrance
soaking more guts
i had to get it from the inside i'll
take one of my own toss a coin to your
witcher oh valley of plenty
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not your friend
oh oh really oh you usually just let
strangers rub chamomile onto your lovely
bottom
where's that scene actually i've always
wanted to know do witches ever retire
yeah
when they slow and get killed come on
you must want something for yourself
until this monster hunting nonsense is
over with i want nothing
except for food women wine
where the [ __ ] am i closed yesterday ah
well uh they were sort of covered in
silky more guts so i said no way to be
washed anyway you're not going tonight
as
a witcher oh he's going out of her cover
i don't have anyone finding out who you
actually are geralt of rick
shaw
[ __ ]
i haven't seen you since the play
good times mosaic
queen callante of cintra
oh i'm gonna love her
i'm so glad you're alive
is he going to be all right
bite down on this
nicely done waters of broken land will
lessen the suffering
they have endured
and make them forget
i think you'd like that you will both
drink the waters
i thought they just learned about this
place they might as well drink the
water we have a renowned guest here
tonight oh my god
we got the spotlight all over
his failures will make for far more
interesting conversation this night
come witch uh
take a seat by my side while i change
she's siri sarah's mom right yeah or i
mean uh fiona yeah i thought they were
ahead
no
yeah i mean i thought they were before i
thought she was before
carol i'm so confused it's happened
it's happened
[Laughter]
i'm princess cirilla cirilla okay so
she's before her storyline's after what
we're watching would go got it got it
yes i thought it was telling that was
reversed i have to find my destiny why
because your grandmother said you should
you should start thinking for yourself
because she is dead
and you are here
oh that's right i thought she was the
daughter yeah she is his granddaughter
okay that's where my whole confusion is
certainly
to this baby i am the whole world
only it weren't so
[Music]
boring time for a little excitement
oh man wow
oh wow whoa
oh dead horses
whoa
woah
[Music]
[Music]
that guy looked like the uh witcher who
died yeah kinda he was paid to kill you
what
why it appears you've ran out of chances
to provide your king a male heir
no he would
wow he's good
the spice
wow
what an exciting ass episode
[Laughter]
three decades she's been here i guess so
yeah jesus the timeline every which way
get up he used his witch
how could you not foresee this you're
supposed to protect me
carefully just call her useless witch
yeah they've been saving her ass this
whole time
[Applause]
[Music]
forgive my late intrusion your majesty i
am lord archaeon of erlenwold
and i have come to claim your daughter's
hand in marriage
what an entrance huh
a night's oath prevents me from
revealing my face until the sounding of
the twelfth bell follows to that
[Music]
this is no monster i order you
this night has been cursed slay this
base
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh no
this is not going the way it's supposed
to go
damn i thought i was happy to see you
again surprise has been cold
you killed them
kill me
[Applause]
no [ __ ] wow and you know he had some
other queens good sir
[Music]
take her instead
there's a sacrifice
[Music]
hell yeah yeah
run baby
the
the knicker
i thought it went past her but i don't
know oh it did yeah i got her shoulder
yeah
dooney
oh they knew each other prior yeah
who are we to challenge destiny
life was saved that must be paid the
whole order of the world falls apart
honor destiny's wish
or unleash it's rough
upon us that's ray's the magic guy
oh
[Music]
i kept wondering we're like where did
the power come from for uh
oh ho
[Music]
wow
sheepers
destiny has spoken
and i have listened she could vary the
thing
there will be two vowels here tonight i
assume that's agreeable
what the hell it's jala movie now
[Laughter]
oh my god is this just blood everywhere
waro vision
why why why yeah
why do that way just cut her head off i
drank the waters
it's gonna be okay
leave your past behind
join us
drink
and forget
will it memory wipe or is she just kind
of being like
for your mind
[Music]
sleep well
she tried so hard to protect the baby
yeah
poor thing
oh sure love curing him or is he dying
worse yeah i could
i can't tell he's making it worse
it's curing him true love catering him
oh the whole crowd's like whew
oh thank god for that oh
i could be on board for this
the 12th house is not yet wrong what has
happened i think your blessing of this
marriage
has fulfilled a destiny
the curse has been lifted
that pesky destiny
you saved my life
i must repay you
you've proven yourself to be the kind of
man who would do the same
i want nothing no please
after all that okay
ultimate badass
i
claim the tradition as you have
the lord of surprise
give me that but you already have but do
not know what have you done witcher fear
not your majesty destiny can go
oh oh my god
siri
destiny
[ __ ]
[Music]
true words are rare birds and corns like
this
watch for daggers in your back
no more likely poison
be careful old friend
ah now episode one bumps ring up
we can spare ten thousand men to take it
sir armies are not the way into
brockland forest damn it
what the [ __ ] oh my dude hey he lives
come on
seriously it would have been a fight to
tell us the bureau through different
timelines
yeah
you just drink from the source
yummy
so that's where the blue milk comes from
tree water must be so nourishing
oh
whoa
wow drink from that tree
[Music]
talks the tree talks
wow
oh man
that was somehow
that was a something episode in the
words of the great eternals movie
that was dense
that was dense that was dense john and
that was dense
yes it was
i love how he
agrees to the law of surprise
just because he was trying to get the
[ __ ] out
really be careful with what you just
throw out there man
especially
a lot of surprise but
let me go
i don't want anything this seems like
the easiest way to knock it oh [ __ ] no i
got even more i got destiny now i hate
destiny what the fudge
so
i mean that works out great this was a
wonderful episode absolutely yeah this
was this was like
this was so rich in every aspect
between oh i mean from all three epis
from all the four episodes we watched
the scene work and the dialogues and the
back and forth was
thoroughly engaging and
that's something that i haven't actually
said about the even though i haven't
really enjoyed the hell out of this
series
that's not something i've been saying
about this show
but this episode in particular in uh
the city is that it's the kingdom ciara
right
sin centra syndra and the the girl is
ciara siri cirilla cirilla god damn it
serious really yeah all right john i'm
counting on you i'm doing my best over
here
um but yes within within the city
that whole like banquet scene that just
from beginning to end it was like a play
yeah it really was especially in the way
things would develop yeah i just love
how it just starts like it was just
non-stop like turns and reveals and
turns and reveals and it really sets the
stage so well like from the from the
get-go from like
the bard
taking down the story of the witcher and
him being kind of like that narrator was
like we know he's fine yeah
and then he shows up to everyone's
surprise and then he attends and it's
like do you think it's going to be some
covert undercover thing he's doing
immediately
yes
he's the most subversive he's talked
about things
he's the most famous guy in the room
yeah and it and that kind of mood just
kept happening throughout that whole
night just twists and turns and reveals
and
the timeline thing is cool
it's neat in this i can imagine what
it's like to go back to the first
episode especially if we like when we
finish the season
then they go back
and how effective that would be because
i remember we were saying how i felt
like we were watching the end of like a
season in that one episode yeah
absolutely because we don't have this
episode here
or an episode like this to get you
invested in them
yeah they're so so when they die it's
like heartbreaking
and then here i'm like man i really felt
low i didn't even recognize the queen at
first because she was all like messed up
oh yeah it took me a second to be like i
can't be here because look at the
daughter here and i don't know were you
aware that
this whole time i i that this whole type
of well we started becoming more aware
of the timelines i thought
uh cyrilla yes i thought she
was
the most present days i mean i thought
she
was before geralt's timeline gotcha
gotcha gotcha i was uh i was confused on
that yeah yeah so uh this whole time i
thought like oh when they beat up she's
going to be older yeah
oh no she's going to be a kid she's
going to be who we say yes
yeah yeah
so i thought she might just look like
the queen and then she was behaving so
different too yeah that it didn't it
just wasn't clicking with me until later
on when we saw the husband i'm like wait
a minute oh wait oh this is the past
because i remember him dying with the
arrow to his eye yeah yeah
he i mean he tipped me off i see funny
enough i didn't recognize the magic guy
at all
it took me a while there's so many other
guys who kind of look like him and then
you start to wonder like oh am i just
remembering wrong the whole person but
yeah when kalanthi walks in
i think it was because she was in armor
and covered in blood and muck i was like
oh that must be the queen from the first
episode because she's
because i remember like noting that i'm
like oh damn she really seems like she's
at home out in battle
yeah yeah but yeah it i i i've grown to
very much enjoy the timeline thing that
they're doing here because it's not
really obvious and sometimes they can
throw you for a loop but that's kind of
become part of the fun of it to me and
also
i've been enjoying the way that they're
displacing these events in ways that
feel
like i
i feel like this will get compared to
game of thrones a ton and i feel like
one of the major differences i don't
feel like it's anything like it anymore
not really and and one aspect of that is
game of thrones you know is so linearly
building all these elements to one great
summit whereas this really does feel
like you're peering in on these various
tales from the same tome this is
exuberantly more fantastical absolutely
and i love but i love the way they
handle the fantastical stuff too because
it is
dazzling but it's also like very
elemental and very like icky too or very
sort of uh
i don't know they they make it tangible
with a lot of different factors like
that you know it's like you get it all
feels like one big black goo
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got trees bleeding
magical elixirs and giant
bug assassin helpers and things like
that and like yeah it's
i i enjoy kind of the the surprise of
being like oh snap we're back in the
past and these characters i never
expected to see again are back but yeah
what they made of that too and the way
they allow you to sit in things that you
know once you catch on might lead to
other things down the line like their
whole you know
you know they make so much out of uh
siri and geralt sharing destiny in the
first episode and you're like at first
that just feels like you know fantasy
story
mumbo-jumbo uh but here it's like i
really loved seeing the origins of that
and also the fact that this episode is
all about people's per or partially
about people's perspectives on destiny
and how people like to either deny or
really marry themselves to the idea and
why
or they use it as a way to just make
themselves feel better about life
or manipulate other people yeah you know
it's there's interesting conversations
here throughout yeah it is cool when
you're watching uh gerald interact with
the queen
and how their rapport
is like henry cavill just gets better
every episode absolutely i mean he was
like
like flawless here i thought like it was
[ __ ] flawless
and like all his little looks like this
is the most fun
it's weird like this is so exciting
and there was it was the thickest one
that we've seen so far
but it was also the most fun
that i've had watching this show too
like it was genuinely just really it's
really fun the whole time
other than when you're in
brooklyn nine-nine where you know
rocklin or something broccoli
brooklyn or yeah brooklyn forest yeah
other than there but everything else was
just so fun but even that was still like
intriguing and mystical and and you know
i'm excited for real
yeah there's like enchanted forest vibes
yeah i like that
um
this is the part i was least engaged by
but just because all the other stuff
that's like the other first like
escaping from assassin and then
then this is like a bunch of scenes and
uncovering the history yeah where her
was more like tone poem stuff and a
little little specific details i'm sure
that's gonna become a much bigger thing
obviously yeah um but that's also why i
probably had the least screen time so
yeah but the it was cool watching girl
interact with the queen and then
watching how
their rapport and sensibilities like
sometimes it was a little bit adjusting
and other times there was a lot of
camaraderie and
yeah you're watching all that unfold
so yes by the time he gets to the point
where
you know he he does the law of some
pretty claims law of surprise and she's
like no that means i mean my
granddaughter is gonna be with you it
still has this much bigger like tortilla
of context as i like to call it because
when she says in the first episode go
find geralt it's a way of hoping for um
cirilla to thrive and i mean live yeah
you know because
you see when you back it with the
interaction you have with geralt geralt
who he is truly morally as a person who
he is as a warrior law of surprise all
that
it's it's more than just
he claimed law of surprise you got to be
with him yeah yeah it's like the hope is
really with him maybe he can protect you
exactly so that's what's awesome about
um watching
it it lends so much more weight to all
of that yeah
i love that i really did love absolutely
yeah it was a good nice little like
fairy tale romance too with the
with the hedgehog guy yeah
dooley or whatever his name was dylan
dylan
built
dan
but yeah and i mean you know that that
whole element of you know this curse and
i thought they made like a lot of nice
stuff out of that and uh
and um yeah i don't know like there's
something about to just the way they
broke apart the pieces of the story and
displaced them throughout the episode
that
uh i i don't know like i it's like
watching cloud outlet have you seen
cloud atlas i haven't this has felt like
kind of like cloud atlas where you're
watching like several different
timelines and they're coming back and
forth with the reach exciting yeah
they're not [ __ ] telling you [ __ ]
yeah yeah just like watching it happen i
kind of like the ride of that a lot and
i mean jennifer across this episode too
like i i appreciate it like she almost
by the end i mean she does by the end of
it she gets a soliloquy like it it's it
starts out it's funny because the last
episode is so triumphant for her
and painful but you know you feel like
you know the next time we see her you
know she's got to be you know in a much
more powerful position and yeah to see
her then struggling with
having to back up the they're having to
support and having to look after these
people who don't appreciate her and
being relegated to dealing with people's
political squabbles and that whole
you know speech she gives on the beach
you know like i she's a woman being
vessels yeah learned a lot
and that was i mean that was
the way that that played out though i
thought was very
interesting and sad because you know
like i i
i was expecting the baby to live or
something especially after all that work
yeah yeah yeah and i mean you know like
the whole thing with the the you know
princess or whatever where she's you
know she's like busting ass to protect
her and after all that she's like
you're worthless like you know like i
thought that that would be the train is
like okay the princess dies um but you
know it's like that is another one of
those details where they don't give you
you know the the cleaner the the
prettier the thing that you want you
know and it is kind of
it is quietly
disquieting to see this you know blue
infant oh yeah they keep coming back to
it sapped of life and yeah like it is
such a such a sad and poignant
moment the way that like it's it's one
of the more thrilling consistent parts
of you know it's like for so much of the
episode it's like a chase and it's got
this like massacre at the beginning and
then to kind of rest that in this quiet
sad poignant back and forth between the
two of them i mean
or at least from the one of them you
know i thought was very striking too
it's a burial speech
absolutely beautiful one mm-hmm
i just hope nobody goes strolling on
that beach i mean jennifer
you can't have jennifer just be in
control or have a power position yet
yeah that's probably makes jennifer
awesome she keeps fighting for it yeah
even though she seems like defeated now
and
whatever 30 decades or three decades so
she might be caught up with geralt
could be
because or right around there it could
be because when we saw in her timeline
the people like
the king and stuff was were children
last time we saw her in the previous
episode yeah so if it's been 30 years
she could be close two girls
see that crossover
i mean it's all it has to be building to
where the three of them are together
right
i don't know if anything has to do
anything you know
but i i am anticipating something like
that or i guess i'm kind of hoping i
mean it would be kind of weird if
jennifer's just
she just has her own story and then
we've got cyrilla and carol just
eventually amounting to beat up i think
no i think it has to be where the three
of them are bound to meet up with each
other yeah yeah that would make a lot of
sense i can't wait for that day to come
well that fight that chase sequence was
so exciting
with the
what we now call sling rings
yes well i love the way they realized
all of that and the way she [ __ ] hard
yeah like that's the that's the great
part
it's like you've got this wonderful
magic but i love that sense of this
takes focus and coordination and energy
and i can't you know beat everything to
everyone in this fight you know yeah
like the location hopping kind of makes
you think of doctor strange and thought
of the dark world or jumper yeah or a
jumper yeah
yeah that was cool but i kept mixing it
in with like cool locations that looked
real yeah and not
like green screen sets yeah yeah well
that's that's another thing that's what
i'm sure i'm sure there's a lot of that
but i i didn't notice it well yeah i
mean like i i know netflix especially
now has a reputation for sparing
few expenses and it really does
communicate here because most every
place we wind up i'm like wow you know
like this
feels like a real place set castle etc
where's
was nelf guard the last episode or two
episodes ago i know it's the second
episode where he meets the guy who lets
him go and they tie him up and
everything
i think it was two episodes ago
because yeah there was those people from
nilfgaard they said okay yeah
yeah yeah that elven king who like talks
to him for a minute and then lets him go
so i needed a notebook when watching yes
so we need like a big old no queen he's
like
notion
we need a big board
here's every carrot
yeah strings color coded to each
timeline
yeah
we're gonna keep proper track of this
goddamn oh yeah that was uh
sometimes they're talking and i'm like
that sounds so familiar
am i
am i if i keep a blank face and maybe
look up if i remember to look this up
before we shoot review part of video am
i overzealously trying to recognize
things and that's confusing myself or do
i really recognize that from a couple
episodes like i didn't recognize anyone
offhand but i see the assassin and i was
like is that the witcher who died what's
going on here
oh boy
well yeah no this was this was an
awesome episode yeah that was great i
loved it i i loved it a lot like it
really feel like it came to life like
this
this to me seems like the show like i've
really been enjoying it a lot uh i've
quite i've been
enjoying it a lot yeah
uh this one just the kind of energy it
brought was so
it feels like it really found its
footing here yeah it felt like
spontaneous but not random and it felt
really engaging and i loved what you
said earlier about it feeling like it
really did feel like a play right down
to like the shakespearean comedy ending
of everyone getting married
like it really did feel like a play
but not in the way where you're like
this should have just been a play like
it really felt cinematic but also it had
that life that a play would have well it
had like big ass set piece out of the
end within that
setting where the power comes through
yeah whatever that's called
the voice yeah
yeah
power use the voice
get the spice okay so then we get a hint
of that too of how
every other
was that established whatever that power
is yeah every other generation i
supposed to get it i vaguely remember
that discussion happening of like your
mom didn't have the power so or
[Music]
the queen had a husband who's dead
yeah
the king who
a hedgehog saved
yes because then she met because i was
that's where i was getting like wait a
minute i thought that guy was the king
yeah yeah yeah no i guess that's about
to happen okay
he's just her buddy right now
yeah
yeah i think you're i think you're right
there
because king wasn't there and she said
you know do you think i wanted to marry
your father yeah to uh
cyrilla's mom
yeah papada taylor swift yes
taylor's version
what's yeah episode for taylor's version
taylor's this is a 10-minute passage
about julie
that's good
you changed when you went back to humans
yeah
now i'm too young for you
i'm aging too much oh no
god poor jake gyllenhaal man
he said ironically or taylor swift yeah
poor taylor swift jake gyllenhaal needs
to go he maybe he's bathing his own
tears right now i mean i would have said
poor taylor swift a few years ago
[Music]
when that song first came out yeah
now that it's just popular again now i'm
like
don't worry there's an even longer
version in the works it's hard to escape
the
most popular female artist in the world
i mean
yeah she's the most popular artist
she's probably i mean she is up there
she is a titan and i mean the fact that
she's now been able to go hey all these
records that i made i'm gonna i'm gonna
redo all these my way yeah suggest that
she's yeah i a heap ton of clout
loopholes
uh yeah guys this was awesome thank you
so much for being here and um
as
intrigued here at my voice i need to
blow my nose
badly thank you vader subscribe click
that bell hit that like button and we'll
catch you guys
[Music]